village elders in this remote island in
the south pacific always believed they
would live out their days here
on prized land where their chiefs lay
buried
but these are the tombstones of that
sacred land
submerged by the ocean
we miss this community so much
because
we learned many things about custom
tradition the way of life here as we
refugees
how we link to the soil how we link to
the land we live in our culture we
understand
as we were taught from our parents
celosi ramatua is the former head man of
the bunidogaloa village the first fijian
village to suffer the effects of climate
change
water had risen up to people's knees
and saltwater had destroyed the ability
to grow crops
now the area is nothing more than a
ghost town
a little further inland in the site of
their adopted home children play with
their feet firmly planted on dry ground
but their elders often return to the old
village to reconnect with their past
they want developed nations to pay for
the damage done to their culture and
their abandoned homes
we want to say if the world can walk
together the leaders of the world can
walk together
in enemies to combat it to the impact of
climate change you know to make a
decision
fiji is an archipelago of hundreds of
islands some 2000 kilometers north of
new zealand
it's the first pacific island nation to
have relocated the community because of
rising sea levels
samisi madanawa and his family are next
located along the coast of fiji's
mainland his village isn't what it once
was
he and his family now weigh up the cost
of moving to higher ground
it takes time it takes time
for an idea to settle in the hearts of
us
human beings so that we can accept
the changes that are coming in
changes that are proving difficult for
the growing list of people displaced by
climate change
jillian wolf al jazeera
roy pomerantz is a senior fellow at the
woodward climate research center he was
also u.s deputy assistant secretary of
state for the environment he joins us
from seneca rocks in west virginia we
very much appreciate your time so uh for
developing nations in particular this
really is a serious emergency isn't it
oh yes and we will only grow more
intense over time as
sea level for example continues to rise
so what will be the human cost
well the human cost well first of all it
depends on how fast and how much sea
level rises
and that depends on
the level of emissions that the world
achieves emission reductions
the lower the emissions the less the sea
level rises but we are in for
a significant amount of sea level rise
no matter what that's baked in
therefore the cost will only go up
and the need for wealthy countries to
assist developing countries and managing
retreat
or the movement of human settlements
will grow it's already a subject of
negotiations internationally
and that will intensify
in practical terms though how difficult
is it going to be with those
negotiations you mentioned to get
more developed nations to do more in
practical terms
well
maybe the most important thing that
developed nations can do number one
would be
to as quickly as possible zero out their
greenhouse gas emissions carbon dioxide
and methane that's a big job
and in the process we're going to commit
ourselves to ever more sea level rise
so developed
countries wealthy countries are going to
have to figure out a mechanism
to finance to help finance the
transition
for people
in vulnerable areas
and those where there is not much wealth
where people are poor
so this is a huge task and we
unfortunately
are just at the beginning
and what if not enough is done then what
will be the effects of this on things
like human migration and general
prosperity
well i don't well we can anticipate a
lot of migration because people have
nowhere to go that is the oceans rise
um
people have to move they either move
inland in their own country or they have
to leave if there's nowhere to go we
face that problem in the united states
already in a place like alaska where
indigenous villages
have to be moved that are on the
coastline because of the loss of sea ice
and the melting of permafrost so we know
a bit about this
and
there are other aspects of climate
change that will cause massive uh
migration including temperature
increases
in latitudes where it's already too hot
and drought
where it's already dry and famine will
will occur as a result of greater
drought so we're faced in a number of
fronts with
movements of population
you know we can anticipate this but
governments aren't very good at getting
ready for crises that
are 10 or 20 or 30 years out
okay we'll leave it there roy pomerance
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here on al jazeera thank you
thank you